hi everyone uh
and today
i i came especially for this meetup from
poland that's
true but not
that's not all the truth regarding my uh
visiting israel
i'm actually uh pretty often here uh
that's one of my favorite cities in the
world i'm in tel aviv so
i'm very sorry i know i know that i'm
but that's why
you know showed this direction
technically i know technically ramangan
is on the city but i think it's it's a
great city as well
um
today we're here um to talk about
leveraging world embeddings um so a
method from natural language processing
for the purpose of building an efficient
recommended system
and what do i mean by efficient i will
tell you in a second
but in the beginning i want to give you
a
brief overview of what we'll be talking
about so we'll start with an intro
then we'll do a short refresher
embeddings
very short but if you will have any
questions feel free to ask them
then we'll talk about
doing recommendations with embeddings so
using embeddings
and at the end we'll talk specifically
what can you do
to make your embeddings
well suited for recommendation for
recommendation settings
right because this method comes from
from nlp and natural languages
they have certain qualities that might
be different than the qualities of
um of uh pro of products our product
descriptions
so five uh sentences about myself
my name is alexander morlak
i work as an innovation lead and
research machine learning research at
lingaro
which is a global company
doing data consulting let's say
i'm an expert in nlp i am
very interested in probabilistic
modeling and causality
i'm the offer of sunday ai papers which
is a
linkedin based micro blog where every
week i review
papers from from last week so like let's
call
a bleeding bleeding
edge staff
i'm also interested in complex systems
psychology and neuroscience and that's a
part of my academic background
and things that i enjoy privately is
traveling with my wife which i'm not
doing this time i'm traveling alone uh
it's also running uh vegan food and
languages
yeah so let's go to the intro and i want
to start with telling you a little bit
about what i mean by efficient so we
talked about efficient recommended
systems most recommended systems in
general
um
and i think this is uh important in the
context of this in this presentation so
first of all i want to talk about a
system that is relatively easy to
develop
second of all it's relatively easy to
maintain
and third of all it offers fast
inference time
you want something that
even for
a large amount of data
is able to provide you with predictions
uh like production grade predictions
so now let's do a quick refresher on
word embeddings that's one of the
definitions of word embeddings that i
found somewhere maybe on wikipedia
i don't think it's the best one but it
has some interesting
interesting thoughts so it says an
embedding is a relatively low
dimensional space
into which you can translate high
dimensional
vectors
so in the context of natural language
those high dimensional vectors are
actually implicit
so we can think about any word that
comes to your mind like maybe
cat
and you can say that
cat can be described as a
virtually
infinite infinitely dimensional vector
this is any mathematical thing
it's got nothing working betting is a
special case yeah an embedding fit here
yeah
yeah it will it would yeah but we are
talking about nlp so that's why i'm
talking about those uh cats
yeah or is there something
deeper in what you said that i didn't
catch
just general thing yeah okay
so for instance cat could be
described by an embedding uh where we
have one dimension that says is it an
animal and that will be a binary one on
one one or zero then maybe has it fair
that will be a probability because
because there are cats without fur and
our cats with fur
and so on and so on and we can think
about those um
dimensions and on and on and when we are
training training um
training
word embeddings we actually have those
high dimensional vectors
um
they're only implicit
and
we are trying to
map them
through
the neighboring neighboring words so we
have words
and their neighbors and we say that the
context says something important about
the word itself and its meaning
and
the most important thing in the context
of of embeddings in general but also
word embeddings is a fact that it gives
us a representation that has some useful
properties
so one of those useful properties is
that things that have similar meaning
or are semantically similar will be
close to each other like cat and dog and
things that are
not
are further away like car and andromeda
for instance
so the way we build the build build
those embeddings the the idea um comes
from
it's it's it's not a new idea
this is a very famous uh
quotation from general preferred from
the 50s
which where he said where he said you
should know a word by the company it
keeps so this is a quotation that you
can find very often in the context of
word and bearings and actually this idea
is even older
and this is another
um sentence this time from ludwig
wittenstein who was austrian jewish a
philosopher for a large class of cases
don't know for all in which we employ
the word meaning it can be defined
thus the meaning of a word is its use in
the language and use is always embedded
in some context this can be context of
other words but it might although also
be situational and this is what viking
style was talking about
another interesting uh property of
embeddings word embeddings
is that we can do a kind of
embedding arbitrary
using those right so we can take some
vectors and i'm pretty sure that
everybody who knows something about nlp
i have seen this illustration before
so we can take a king vector for king
subtract man add woman and we should and
we are expecting that we'll get
something very close to the vector for
full queen
so
now if we can
use this arithmetic for words
uh could we also use this for for
products for instance
so i think we could use it for products
and
there are a couple of useful things here
so first of all
we might embed products that are similar
close to each other in this
embedding space
that's useful per se i guess because as
you can think
think of it it's easy to search the
points that are close to each other
a product oh okay yeah that's a very
good question so a product is
represented either by some code or maybe
just its name or maybe its description
so any of those will work
so so the product is like um
dry gin something 300 milliliters
apples one kilogram
um it might also be just a coat for
apples which would be 200 4 or 500 right
so any of those would do and they will
have slightly different um properties
we will talk about this a little bit in
a bit in a bit more detail later
so
so one um interesting property is that
we have those
points that are that similar products
should be
somewhere close in this page but another
one is that
we might be interested in recommending a
product based not just on one product
but on a whole basket of products
and now thanks to this
arithmetic that we have here
we can build an abstract representation
of a basket of products and it will be
somewhere in this space okay the
dimensional space
okay so how to do it
um
first of all we have a couple of
different scenarios that we can
find useful in our use case
so we can model inter-product relations
which means that we have a basket of
products
and we want to embed them
in the embedding space
and then
be able to use all of those features
that we
talked about
and i talked about before
another use case is that we might want
to leverage uh meta relations between
those products
so for instance you can imagine a
supermarket
and in the supermarkets you will have
aisles
now where you have maybe one is with
vegetables and another one is with
vegan products
and then
you might be interested in not only
modeling the relationship
between the products within someone's
basket
but also
a relationship between products
given that they come from a given ale
so this is something we can also
do
and finally we might be interested in
encoding morphological information
about products so
leveraging
the information that is encoded in their
names or descriptions
and this comes
comes back somehow to your question
about what is a product because if we
represent a product as a code
then this last
thing
won't work for us right
um but otherwise when we have names and
those names are meaningful so maybe
apples 200 grams and apples one kilogram
does seem like there are similar
products and then we can
encode this morphological information
this first use case
we can actually model this using a plain
word to vac model
that you
the
who who who has heard about word to back
model
okay so like almost everyone
the second one um if you want to
leverage the second one so if you want
to add metal relations
we might be interested in using another
model which is called metapro to back so
who has heard about this pro this model
it's like two people three people
okay so i'll tell you a little bit about
this
so in word to vag as you probably know
we are either trying to predict the
context given
a word
or we are trying to predict a word
given the context so that would be
a skipper model or sibo or continuous
back of word small
in metaprop to vag
we are not only taking
the product embedding so the product
name let's say but we are also taking
the context
and we are modeling jointly both
so you can think of it as
trying to
predict the context
predict the context
and the product
based on another product in its context
so for instance we can go back to this
uh
example of ale
so we say maybe vegetables
and then carrot one kilogram
and then another product in our basket
would be
beverages and
code zero for instance right so now we
are not looking at
single items
in a vector of our products and context
but we are looking at
tables okay so we're trying we are
taking into account tuples
um
it looks maybe a little bit more complex
than word to veg but in practice it's
not really
not really more complex than the model
so we just need those tables and we need
to make sure that those tuples are
always together so when we shuffle our
data for instance
we make sure that our context and
product names are one next to each other
to encode morphological information
we can use another
[Music]
let's say
another type of word direct model
actually which is called fast text who
has heard about fast text
[Music]
so it's like 50 percent so so the main
idea behind fastex it's very similar to
word to back um the main difference is
that we before we are embedding uh the
tokens in the space
we are splitting them
into sub words
and those sub words how we split those
words into sub words
uh is usually
driven by
uh the frequency of those subwords so
maybe d e like that
would be uh
one sub word
and um i don't know s e and s a would be
another star word
does this make sense
okay so let's see how to implement it
that will be very high level
but just to give you a glimpse
so
one remark here is that
every all the code that is here
is using ginseng api version 3.8
which is
one before the current one which is 4.0
i guess
4.01
[Music]
um
this is very straightforward so we just
import the class
or direct from from gensym
and then we just pass the data
our parameters and some callbacks if you
if you want to use them and our data
should be in the form of
a list of lists or an array of arrays of
strings
so now i want to talk about
hyperparameters a little bit um this
goes back this goes back to
what we
said in the beginning
um
that there are some attributes of
natural language that are not necessary
attributes of let's say
products product descriptions and so on
uh
who of you has uh has heard about zip
flow
zip law
yes it's law sorry yeah
okay so it's like yeah
i'm thinking so i'll
talk about this uh briefly
uh but but let's start with the
architecture so we said in the beginning
most of you are familiar with word
vector
model and we said that there are these
two
different
uh architectures called sibo continuous
type of words and skip gram
and
for recommended systems
from my experience skip gram usually
works better
it's either they are either
very very similar all skip drum is
better so from my experience i would say
that if you want to use this for
recommended systems skip should be your
way to go on could be your way to go
now
another um or let's say the first of the
hyper parameters when we decide on the
architecture is called sub sampling
so this is a very important and
parameter and if you know the original
word to back
paper from from micholofinal
you will
you might remember that they also
talk about this
so subsampling reduces probability of
using the most frequent or the least
frequent depending on the parameters
here where it's in the training
um
this formula comes from google
implementation of word to back so it's
slightly different from the one in the
paper
but they are very similar and
just to see what it what it does
like one more thing i will i'll go back
here
uh so so
in the word to back paper
the value of k
is just some constant right the value of
k is point zero zero one
we'll see this in the in the graph in a
second
[Music]
so
0.001 is the yellow line
so here you can see
um
the frequency
and
yeah and you see that
the words that has very low frequency
have very high probability of
of um being taken into account when when
we train them all
well words with like very high frequency
their probability is much much better
but much much lower i'm sorry
yeah so why is that anybody has an idea
what that could be
everyone buys eggs
yeah that's a good one but when we go
back to the natural language natural
language setting why would we like to
um
train on the words that are less
frequent in the language rather than on
the ones that are very very frequent
like story positions
and positions like all these syntactic
stuff that's not very unique
yes exactly exactly that's a very good
answer so
the first answer was that everybody buys
x
this is a this is an important uh
realization when it comes to recommended
systems but when it comes to natural
language processing the answer was that
all the syntactic stuff
things like the
things like a
uh they are not really meaningful so we
we are not really interested in modeling
them
but for the recommended system actually
of course it depends on your setting uh
but for many of those we actually want
to recommend products
that are popular
yeah
of course that depends on your setting
to some extent but in many settings
we if we sell a lot of something
we want to sell sell even even more of
this so that's why for
recommender
system setting we would rather go with
line like this which is almost flat
as you can see so that would be
something
close to zero
um
another very important parameter is
negative
called negative sampling so word to back
in where to back we are not taking all
the samples as our negative samples
because that would be very very
inefficient so we are trying to sample
some negative words
um
to make the training
feasible and much more efficient
um
there's another formula here but i will
show you the the plot
so that's the frequency of um
of words uh versus their probability of
being chosen as a negative example
and as you can see the yellow line again
shows the values for
so so um shows the distribution for the
value for natural language that was uh
proposed by mikodov
and it goes like it's a little bit lower
here a little bit higher here but for
recommended system
again we have slightly different
situation
so
we want to take something that is
very infrequent as our negative examples
pretty often and this is something that
worked for us in practice many many
times
in different settings like retail
like hr
and so on and for
for actually
all the projects that's that's i use
this method um for
the values between
minus 0.5 minus 0.45
and minus 0.55
are optimal while for natural language
processing we usually use something
around 0.75
for english it seems that it's an
optimal value
if you want to go into
into more details on this there's a very
nice paper in this called word to vec
applied to recommendation hyper
parameters matter
uh from guys from diesel
i don't even know if this service still
exists
and this is an example of a set of hyper
parameters
um that i actually used in one of our
projects so the embedding dimension is
300
window size is 9 here and
9 works well if you have if you are
modeling
now with the context so using uh metapro
today
and then then we had two context levels
right so there was a hierarchical
relationship
of two levels and then product and then
a product
but for if you have like a flat
non-hierarchical
situation where you only have products
then
a window size that is a 95 of maximum
length
of your let's say basket
uh
works pretty works pretty well
and then you see that the
negative negative exponent is minus 0.5
so something we discussed before
and sample which is sub sampling is
is zero here
and that was these values were actually
tuned using some some bayesian methods
so
uh so they come from from tuning on
other particular problem
so now if we have a recommended system
over like a very very large search space
one of the problems is that it might be
hard to find those nearest neighbors
so for this
there's a method called hierarchical
navigable small worlds which is a
non-metric which maps this metric
embedding space into a non-metric space
and builds a
kind of a hierarchical structure that is
very very easily searchable and this
gives you a very high recall
with like a very very
fast
inference time so we use this for
a data set where we have
over four million entities
and for those those four million
entities were able to get predictions in
less than 100 milliseconds
yeah why don't you use the
inner product
um i think it's um
well i think i think that will be
slower
how does it form
so this um this maps a metric space of
embeddings which is like in this case it
was 300 dimensional
it maps it into a non-metric non-metric
space based on the graph
it's not actually one graph it's a
hierarchical
layered graph structure
yeah
so this i know this is a kind of high
level um
answer but it will be hard for me to
describe the very uh in a very detailed
way but if you're interested in this i
can i can link you a couple of papers on
this which are very interesting but you
mean that hierarchy is what makes it
yes it's one of the aspects yeah
and another one is that they're yeah
it's more of us
it's more robust inner product
tend to be non-robust okay so yeah so
the so the remark here was that the
inner product
um tends to be not very robust this is
very robust yeah so
you can get like a very high recoil i
was actually
comparing this method to
um to the exact search
and in most cases
that was like 100 coverage so they were
identical in most cases
now but there's there's like a very good
benchmark somewhere in github where
people
uh
just did a shootout between many many
methods including this one
and this one is really really super
superior when i read this for the first
time i was like wow i'm so stunned you
know
so uh if you're interested in this let's
link on linkedin and i'm very happy to
uh to send you some materials on this
and uh another interesting thing is
multi-entity type scenarios so this
might be
for for instance you might be interested
in embedding different entity types in
one space
maybe it's it would be like in hr space
skills
job titles and employers
and now when you do this
it has some advantages some
disadvantages
but if those advantages
are important to you then it might be a
good idea
but uh one problem that that appears
then is
that
if you want to search for an employer
given a set of skills for instance
and your data is slightly noisy which
means that
you will have some actual skills
as employers
then before you
in the space you reach to employers
you will go through all the skills
including those that are not real skills
but
those noisy employers actually
and this makes it very very hard to
actually make it useful
and to deal with this one simple and
good idea is to do space partitioning
which means that after the training in
one joint space
you just partition this space into in
this example three different parts
and then if you want for instance get a
job title given a set of skills
you just embed the skills
build a representation for all of them
and then search the space of job titles
using this representation
there are a couple of insights that i
would like to share with you
so
when training
shuffling either helps or is neutral
in many cases for me it helped
although
i was convinced that the data is already
shuffled when i got it i thought it has
like completely random ordering
uh but something helped many times for
me some but sometimes it's neutral so
it doesn't help you know one thing
to remember is that if you
use meta meta prototag
then you need to remember that you need
to keep the ordering of your tuples
right into shuffle tuples
not each of the
not each of the entities in your list
another one something that we talked
about before skipgram usually performs
better than continuous bank of words in
this context
uh euclidean distance outperforms
angular distance in some scenarios this
is something that i was
surprised myself
by at some point
because
if you think about those metrics like
especially business metrics in
higher dimensional spaces they tend to
lose their meaning right
if the space is very very highly
dimensional
euclidean distance will tend to go to
zero
and just lose its meaning but in some
sense in some um in some scenarios it
performed much much better than
um
than angular distance which was cosine
similarity in this case
and
and
it was
like more than twice better so it was
really a significant improvement
cosine similarity assumes all the
vectors come out from the same location
same spot
so the remark uh so the remark is that
cosine similarity assumes that all the
vectors come from the same spot the same
origin right is that what you mean yeah
the same origin
and an euclidean distant distance does
not assume this and i think that it's a
it's a very good hypothesis so in a
sense uh when we measure
constant similarity we might have a
couple of vectors that are one behind
another from our perspective and then
another set of vectors that are one or
points that are one behind another and
now cosine similarity for all those uh
points will will be virtually the same
while for including distance it won't be
right so i don't know if that's exactly
what you thought yeah
sorry
there's
if you project
that you use the projected geometry of
the
green space you get the
angular
networks yeah so
yeah projective space that was the
remark on
yes
yes it's very nice of your
recommendations i just want to ask you
in this world of hyperbaria
tuning and rpi model tuning
do you think that we don't need this
like
accommodations anymore and we can just
just base our data and
let it
just tell it run for the night
testing all those
uh
all those possibilities and just output
the perfect model
like possible
stage maker or other pipelines
so so the question is is it possible
to run this type of model using
sagemaker or another cloud-based service
right
those accommodations itself and and if
this service would be able to find these
recommendations uh itself
do you think that we are at this point
like
um
one challenge that we have here with
recommendation systems i think is
it's not always very straightforward to
find a good metric right to optimize
so in some cases
we were using a
very simple statistical frequencies or
like frequency table as our comparison
metric right so
so that was um let's say that was our
test set yeah we're using this as our
test set
now if you have a good metric though i
think that's perfectly possible because
this is actually
just a regular hyper parameter tuning
scenario right so
if you have a good metric and a good
test set
then you can just put it in some auto
ml
stuff or like
automated hyper parameter tuning stuff
and it should give you all those uh
parameters
does it answer a question
yes but
those are like
fine grained
methods and
we
we are thinking about even in the
in the modern level like uh
we're just thinking about it
giving you the data
with the labels i'm going to
make home and coming in the morning and
just
so um
yeah so one thing that
is different here from from the scenario
that you described because you said
something i will repeat this for for the
recording uh is it possible that we just
give the data and the labels put it to
the service and come back in the morning
and have the model trained is that
correct
is my understanding correct of a
question yeah yeah okay
so
that would be possible of course but
here we don't have labels right most of
the time we might have some
baskets like other baskets of products
that people bought maybe
but there are no labels so this is like
an unsupervised learning scenario
what we are trying to optimize here is
is a type of
essentially a contrastive loss right so
we are trying to infer
labels quote unquote labels from the
context and that's and that's all
and that's what i what i
said before
that if you have a good
test set
or validation set and a good metric to
compare your test set and or validation
set with the outputs from the model then
you can do it with automated hyper
parameter tuning because then it becomes
just an optimization problem right maybe
a little bit more complex than some
other problems maybe a little bit less
complex than another set of problems but
it's just an optimization problem but we
don't have
explicit labels here i would say
does it answer a question
yeah
okay
i have two questions
how do you how will you change these
things that you have uh
including
and then you consider using some payment
or another sentence
instead of autodesk
capture the context
so so the first question is about
language
i'll speak like so the first
so the first question is about
how could we leverage this in a
multilingual
setting right
and the second one is could we use
another
type of embeddings like maybe bird
or something like dynamic embeddings
so
when it comes to multilingual
setting you can try
a couple of things so you can write
translations that's one thing
if you have
a good basis for translations that would
not not always be the case
you can try uh also that's something
that
um we're working on in in one of the
projects you can you can just train
different models for different markets
if your languages are related to markets
because then those markets might have
their own
ways of being right so so then that's
another thing uh if you're in a in a
scenario where
where you can use pre-trained embeddings
so maybe you you don't have just product
names but maybe descriptions that are
more comprehensive
then you can use use some pre-trained
embeddings maybe fast text
uh fastx works really well for automatic
language detection if you don't want to
use apis like google translate and so on
um so i think those representations are
kind of good
to give you
a reliable multilingual
multilingual space does it answer your
first question
yep okay
the second question was about dynamic
embeddings
paraphrasing if you will
um certainly you can use dynamic
embeddings
but
um
in the context of this talk they would
not necessarily
meet the criteria that i
gave in the beginning for being
efficient right so the inference time
for for bet is i mean it's doable to
have it in production and
and and low latency but it's much more
challenging this system you can actually
run it serverless
so you can put it in azure functions
maybe or
gcpe or cloud i don't remember um
the name of this service yeah but
there's there's one gcp or aws lamp
there
so this is this kind of efficiency right
uh so for bad that would not work
but of course if you have more resources
you might use bird
but i would see birds
as meaningful probably in the
more comprehensive
description scenario we don't have just
product names
uh if you just have product names or
product codes
i don't know i don't have a good
use case in my mind just like just like
this maybe there is one but
i i don't have one that would justify
the overhead for development and
inference time
and maintenance as well
does it answer your second question yeah
thank you
you cleaning distance uh and
the fourth point here was about space
partitioning
so this is something that we also talked
about briefly
this might make your system uh
faster when it comes to inference
and just
make it much more robust if your data
is somehow noisy so space partitioning
might might help
you address these two questions
so pros and cons
uh first i think it's easy to maintain
very easy to maintain
you can schedule automatic retrainings
you can train it continuously as well
so you can just you know
train train when the new data comes but
not from just from scratch
um you can model complex interactions so
this is um a big advantage over
let's say um
some simpler methods
then it supports continuous training
that's something that's already said
it's relatively fast to train
relatively because if your data set is
huge it might train even on a large
machine for a couple of days
it has ultra fast retrieval times using
as
h and sw
and it can be easily served in a
serverless fashion depending on the
number of tokens because if you're
if your vocabulary is really huge it has
like i don't know hundreds of millions
of tokens it might be it might be
challenging to go serverless but in most
cases that i worked with
it worked pretty smooth so you just
like in the implementation like
because you're using sagemaker with x
points so you're suggesting that using
the
sim
we can volume
with aws lambda
yeah lambda one would be one solution if
you're if you're if aws is your cloud to
to go cloud then lambda should should
should do the job here
intensive
foreign
no sorry i didn't understand the the the
last just like a
function that's running
function yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's
running you need some code around this
usually because you need to pass your
query and
stuff around this but
um essentially it's it's a json model
inside of
inside of
some some wrapper code some boilerplate
code yeah
does this answer your question
yes
maybe i'm just thinking maybe we need to
like
model with our
predictions with with this
great i mean that's if you will find
this useful i'll i'll be more than happy
you know
and that's the best thing uh that you
that you can get get out of and talk
like this if somebody comes here and
then goes and tries this in their use
case and it helps them somehow so
yeah and there are a couple of cons as
well so
if the main one i would say it's not
suitable for call star scenarios which
means that if you don't have
a lot of data in the beginning it will
be very hard for you to build meaningful
embeddings right so
you need to have data first and then you
can train the system
uh the second thing
that i found very challenging in some
projects that i worked at
that i worked in was that if the data is
noisy
the predictions might be noisy as well
so
there is virtually no mechanism
in where to vac
that can help you out of the box can
help you
with denoising your data and there might
be many different types of noises
the one that is
the most annoying in this case is when
you have entities when you have a
multi-entity scenario
and you have mass in your entities so
maybe you have ntda
type of entity a
and type of entities a b and c and then
you have some entities a in your in the
in the set of your c c entities so so
that's a very difficult might be very
difficult scenario
and
that's the last thing i wanted to share
with you
so thank you so much uh if you have any
more questions this is a very good
moment for for them
uh how do i explain that euclidean loss
is better and have i tried other types
of losses
uh so so uh when we are talking about
euclidean distance here it was not um
in the context of loss function sorry
yeah it was about distance so um
so i think sorry i forgot your name
okay so i think this is what abhill said
before that if we have some points
that are you know
one behind another from some perspective
um and then we have another set of
points
that
are one behind another from the same
perspective looking from the source
then cosine similarity might might not
work very well because
all the similarity between all those
points in those two groups will be the
same
while euclidean distance might
should capture the differences between
between them and i'm not sure if it's
answered your question because
vice versa okay you have like the same
distance with different angles
and mistakes
okay
how the fact that uh if you have points
in a sphere that have the same distance
from the center of the sphere
um
is related to two embeddings how does
that work right
that's
like an artifact it is an artifact
that's true
um
though i think we need to remember that
we are not in three-dimensional space we
are in much higher dimensional space and
if we are lucky enough um
so the points are spaced in a way
that can be still meaningfully measured
by euclidean distance
it's very unlikely that they will have
exactly the same distance uh from from
one point in this 300 dimensions
that's at least my observation when i
was looking at the systems right so
um
from the projections like lower
dimensional projections of those
embeddings that i worked on
um i suppose that sometimes in some
cases
they actually form a spherical some some
spherical shapes sometimes these are
bubbles like we talked about this
multi-entity
scenario where we have maybe skills job
tiles employers
they tend to form three separate bubbles
in the 300 dimensional space but the
spacing between points within those
bubbles
is it's really the case that those
distances are very very similar between
any three points let's say
um of course this is something that
that's another uh type of noise that we
have in this type of systems which is
inherently
connected to the nature of this system
and
what you actually mentioned
now
this goes back to a question that i
would say is somehow philosophical so
what does it mean to be similar right
is it only co-occurrence is it uh
is it semantical is it like a semantic
and semantic similarity
is it maybe
something something else what do we mean
by this as humans right
now
these points might be close to each
other for
for for many reasons one of them is that
they are directly neighbors in many many
records right
but
as we said in those
pros here we can also model very complex
interactions so they might be very close
because of some spurious correlation
that goes through many many different
products right
because with every iteration when you
train word to back this you modify the
whole space in a sense
right so this is a challenge and i don't
have a
simple answer to this question
i could say that for um
whatever reason i'm i mean i cannot find
a like a definite
theoretical justification for this but
for whatever reason
if your data is not very noisy this
system
just
tends to work very well so the outputs
are usually very meaningful
if your data is is noisy it becomes
problematic and i don't know if this
answer your question that was very long
a very long answer but i don't have a
definite one and try to give a little
bit of broader context
is it satisfying yes yeah okay thank you
so much
okay
any more questions maybe one or two
because i feel like
we already
use a lot of time right
okay
[Applause]